هكذا بدل المشهد في العاصمه السودانيه قبل
قليل في هذه الصور التي وردتنا من هناك
حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره بسماع يدوي مستمرا
للانفجارات مع تصاعدي اعمده الدخان بكثافه
في وسط الخرطوم ومحيط القصر الجمهوري
اضافه مراسلنا ان المضادات الارضيه
التابعه للدعم السريع ترد على طلعات جديده
لسلاح الجو السوداني في الخرطوم البحري
وكانت المعارك قد تجددت بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في العاصمه
الخرطوم واشار مراسل الجزيره الى سماع
دويا في جراث وسط الخرطوم وتصاعد دخانا
عند مقرن النيلين وسط تحليق لطائرات
الحربيه بمحيط القصر الرئاسي واجواء
الخرطوم بحري
ينضم الينا منهم درمان وراسي الجزيره هيثم
ويتا كيف تبدو الاجواء في هذه اللحظات
ايثم بعد هذا القصف شديد التي تعرض له مقر
رئاسيه في الخرطوم
نعمل الان حاله من الهدوء تسود هذه
المناطق ومعظم اجزاء الخرطوم بعدها
مواجهات عنيفه كانت خلال الساعات الماضيه
المؤشر الاساسي كان فيها هو الهجمات
الجويه والضربات الجويه التي نفذها سلاح
الجو التابعه للجيش على مواقع لقوات الدعم
السريع وفي المقابل كانت هذه القوات ترد
بالمضادات الارضيه للطائرات التي كانت
تحلق في سماء الخرطوم خاصه منطقه وسط
الخرطوم حيث
خاصه ان منطقه وسط الخرطوم حيث المقر
الرئاسيه والقصر الرئاسي والعديد من
المؤسسات السياديه هذه الحاله كانت طوال
اليوم تشهد مواجهات عنيفه وكثيفه ايضا في
بحر كان هناك ايضا جانب هذه المواجهات
شهدته منطقه شنبات شهدت مواجهات مباشره
بالاسلحه الثقيله وايضا بالاسلحه المتوسطه
هذه المواجهات طبعا في الاسبوع الرابع
منها من عمرها وما تزال هي تسيطر على
المشهد الميداني في السودان خاصه في هذه
المناطق التي باتت يعني تلقي هذه
المواجهات بظلالها السالبه على كثير من
نواحي الحياه في منطقه سواء كان الخرطوم
او ام درمان او بحري او المناطق خارج
الولايه التي تتاثر ايضا في شمال كردفان
وفي بعض مناطق دار الفورد هذه المواجهات
بطبيعه الحال تمضي في وقت ما تزال فيه
الهدن المعلنه متعثره وتواجه الكثير من
المصاعب وحتى الان لم تنجح اي من هذه
الهدن في اخماد اصوات البنا هذه المحجمات
المتواصله رغم ان الحديث الان يجري في جده
عن المفاوضات التي تحدث الى ايجاد هدى
مؤقته او وقف اطلاق نار مؤقت
للسموح لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
وبالتالي ايضا التمكين المواطنين من قضاء
حاجياتهم ولكن حتى هذه النقطه الى الان
بدات منذ يوم السبت وحتى هذه اللحظه يبدو
انه لم يتم الوصول الى هذه الغايه التي من
اجلها ذهبت وفود التفاوض الى جده وما زال
الشارع السوداني هنا يتابع بقلق شديد هذه
المفاوضات التي تعتبر بالنسبه لهم مخرج
امان من الازمه الحاليه شكرا لك هيثم
مراسل الجزيره المتحدثه الينا منذ ام
درمان